perché dans les montagnes du var c'est
l'un des plus beaux villages de france
c'est aussi donc plus à soi frites ça
tient à quoi il ya une source qui est
défaillante un fourrage qui est
complètement défaillant une marche plus
et c'est comme ça qu'un quartier de la
commune a été en quelque sorte menacé de
privation d'eau
et la panne sèche ce camion citerne fait
huit voyages de ravitaillement tous les
jours il va chercher de l'eau dans une
commune voisine qui permet de
redistribuer 64 mille litres d'eau tous
les habitants
comme tous leurs voisins les moutards
ont dû apprendre l'économie de l'eau
chaque citoyen ne peut consommer que 150
litres d'eau par jour
plus question d'arroser les fleurs les
arbres et le potager il recycle l'eau
qui leur vendent les mains pour quelques
plantes en pot
mais les plans de framboises dont les
fruits étaient tant attendu par nos
petits fils sont morts 1 était un peu
sans saveur mais ça va pour le moment ça
fait une provence triste et on a beau
essayer de prendre des tomates a lancé l
on trouve pas le goût que sont les
nôtres geneviève la femme de jean michel
aussi s'accommode bien des restrictions
en place pour l'instant si ça pouvait
rester comme ça ça bah oui seulement
comme choisi pour ce qui est à venir on
ne sait pas parce que si le camion un
plus oui et surtout s'il n'y a pas de
pluie quand des mois et des mois
ça va être très compliqué ma peur quand
même ici
c'est assez influent un feu d'habitation
enfin
on a de l'eau mais il n'y a pas de
pression les craintes de l'ancien
pompier volontaire qui a passé des
années à combattre les feux de forêt
comme ceux qui font rage dans d'autres
régions du pays sont loin d'être
infondées
une centaine de communes manquent d'eau
potable en france et c'est un chiffre
qui pourrait bientôt doubler avec les
vagues de chaleur torride successives se
sont aujourd'hui 73 communes qui sont en
état de crise partout sur le territoire
dans les bouches-du-rhône gémenos a
toujours de l'eau potable mais la ville
n'en demeure pas moins en état de crise
avec ce niveau d' alerte le plus élevé
viennent une série d'interdictions
décrétée par le préfet ici aussi pelouse
et potagers doivent être laissés à eux
mêmes les voitures devront aussi
attendre pour être lavé les piscines ne
peuvent plus être remplies une fontaine
de la ville sont à sec tout est mis en
oeuvre pour conserver l'eau potable
bonjour c'est la poésie l'environnement
madame c'est une pelouse synthétique
vous avez devant d'accord c'est ça elle
est très bien imités pas de problème
donc avec le gazon synthétique
par contre le petit potager de la dame
et a normalement verdoyant elle la rose
le soir reconnait-elle avec de l'eau de
son puits or le puits est considéré
comme une ressource locale dont vous
avez plus besoin d'arroser même le
potager d'accord
les agents de la police de
l'environnement font de plus en plus de
ce genre de contrôles dans les zones qui
sont touchés par la sécheresse
un exercice qui sert encore à la
sensibilisation des citoyens au respect
des règles en vigueur mais qui peut
conduire à des constats d'infraction et
à des amendes c'est que ce que vous avez
fait il faut cibler notre action à
gémenos la situation a atteint des
niveaux inquiétants bien avant les
chaleurs caniculaires de l'été à la
famille et moi qui ont suivi n'ont fait
qu'aggraver lancé chemin de la source il
n'a pas plu depuis le 23 juin de cette
année donc ça fait à peu près 50 jours
sans une goutte d'eau sur le département
des bouches du rhône avait température
qui a été très élevé 1 qui frôler les 40
degrés ou dépassée dès cambrai du jamais
vu c'est ce qui décrit le mieux
l'étendue et la durée du problème si le
choc fait l'unanimité le pessimisme est
lui aussi très répandue il faut se
préparer en tout cas avoir des
situations qui sont de plus en plus
extrêmes la sécheresse peut-être comment
d'octobre pas la rade inondations parce
qu'on en aura peut-être plus haut mais
tri excessive cette fois ci et c'est ça
aujourd'hui c'est la succession
d'événements extrêmes
sans financement
cette pelouse bien grasse verte
ruisselante et les fleurs vibrant juste
à côté n'échappe pas aux agents de
l'office français de la biodiversité
d'autant qu'ils sont juste devant la
mairie on s'attend à un respect
exemplaire des règles ici le merde
gémenos n'est donc pas à l'abri des
contrôles de la police de l'eau vive et
rouille erreur j'avais cherché toute la
journée
voilà on compte sur vous et sur vos
équipes
nicolas s'il vous plaît d'otomaï
m'emmène à l'évêché donnez moi me couper
cette
le temps reste bon enfant mais il n'y
aura pas de passe droit je m'en veux
mettre en discrétion par rapport aux
caméras le dossier sera remis au
procureur qui pourrait imposer à
l'administration de la ville une amende
de 7500 euros c'était l'enfer je sais
aussi déjà rêvé pour les particuliers
les amendes imposées peuvent aller
jusqu'à 1500 euros c'est à dugazon a
séduit cette dame devra elle aussi
expliqué pourquoi cette parcelle de son
terrain et toujours vers tous les
imprimeurs je voulais montrer chez les
arbres de mes grands parents qui en dix
ans et qui ont dix ans comme s'entend
qui c'est moi c'est tout en train de
mourir je perds tous les arbres perdent
leurs feuilles les jardins de leur
superbe et les français eux perdent un
peu tous leurs repères ici marie ève
bédard radio-canada dans les bouches du
rhône